music exists in the ear of the beholder
people have been able to find sounds in
the mundane in the extreme and
everything in between
how we make play and listen to music
differs greatly there is so much more
out there than what we might initially
expect so we're looking back and
exploring the sounds and the people
behind them to get a renewed sense of
what music sounds like we get that we're
kind of weird it's a little bit of a
wacky idea we play a wide variety of
typewriters a lot of what we do in
building up songs is really exploring
what different sounds we can get out of
the typewriter and how we can
incorporate them into a song we've
discovered that this makes some
legitimate music and it can be a real
serious endeavor and it's really is
something that sit down listen to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to watch a theremin being played looks
really strange but it's controlled
without any physical contact
[Music]
it's such a new instrument still but
there's nobody who's going to stand
there and say you're not doing it the
way it's supposed to be done I don't
think there's anything else like it
[Music]
a normal instrument you're playing it
and you're expecting it to have a sound
that is pleasing but with an instrument
like this the goal is to just produce
sounds that's in this case so disturbing
we're dealing with things that stir-fry
my emotions and feelings it's not music
in the traditional sense at all but let
me put it this way
the apprehension engine definitely
evokes an emotion so I would call it use
it to play the greats to like pipe organ
is quite a different sensation because
it's like you are becoming one with the
instrument in a very true way you just
sit and go yes
it's something incredibly different and
wonderfully beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Lisa
just more Van Tassel Anderson in common
Samsung control
Yahoo Yahoo Yahoo when Elana sample
there's also some cool occupied a Sun
colliding oh yeah boy young Shin Hwa
Yong
[Music]
no singing is a very ancient and
traditional way of singing you press
your throat and you you generate one
sound but then you generate an over to
on the top of it within your mouth
though it sounds like to sound at the
same time
people think is something really cool
because they never heard about this kind
of thing before you know Oh Mongolian
rock they thing is something very neat
me and pops we beatbox anywhere all day
don't even know if we really know he'd
be back cook any barbershop
this is jam session just us having fun
this this is how a bond with my child
she created her own style when it comes
to beatboxing everyone has to create
I'll put the personal stamp on hip hop
and that's also a hip hop's means it
means a freedom of expression